welcome to this video on playing against
jarrow from Belgium rated 2075 you
notice my rating has plummeted again I
made a conscious decision to play a
couple of games without recording as I'm
simply no I think it simply don't score
I lose all the time they thought maybe
some some easy games without video would
help but it didn't didn't I just lost
and lost and lost and now I'm trying a
different approach I'm not trying to to
do recording like usual but I just play
my absolute mainline openings no
experiments no nothing trying to to get
to stay within my normal comfort zone
and I'm hoping that this net something
okay okay we have an Italian game not
very exciting but solid for white what
I'm also trying to do is not not invest
too much time most of those games that
I'm losing is with me being low on time
I mean I always I'm always low on time
which is a bit due to the to the
comments but still I'm very slow at the
moment wait i od for is no threat not so
sure what this is all about maybe b4 b5
possible
Kim well d5 we can take e5 this is not
not possible now I can build d5 here no
still 95 not a good idea or maybe this
one he cannot play 95 so it should help
me to exchange some stuff and I met on
the clock at least that that is
reassuring that's unexpected really yeah
I'm not sure he takes us probably not
bad as well sin go busy playing 95 now
unbelievable in the moment that's really
unbelievable what's happening him okay
let's store thank mom takes knight c6
yeah this is good for wide I can take
and play rock t3m but it's not exactly
what I what I hoped for yeah it's not
bad at all but I didn't see this before
and at all okay let's see cannot play
Bishop e3 well okay he can as we see he
can but it damages the pawn structure
enormously
so rip dajon I need to take the file the
question is what to do after look
everyone which you probably will play to
do something on their phone not sure
what but something yeah i can pick and
play of 6 and just try to keep
everything protected or i can maybe
something else what about coming here
yeah yeah Queen may be up to e7 this is
winning a tempo also on the pawn on III
was check and if you need to play some
Queen f3 I can still play a 60 watt and
I've got rooked d3 possibly I don't want
to to use a piece to camera f7 and rock
d3 is real threat here at least I'm
getting is root 2 in passive position to
you one I had a 5 thanks okay come on
let's get the rook back from the f file
I can also take a five but i'm not sure
that i should do that it's got Queen f5
possibly Quinn f5 and and to see eight
tags
yeah but I can I can I can return with
Luke here check I thought Quincy five
would be good now yeah this threatens
only three again added tens Queenie
seven and rock f6 is not working takes
Queen takes King yet there is no
perpetual or something 26-27 yeah and
this Hank side Queenie seven getting the
queen of my back yeah he wants to go
here yeah but this is not relieve
threatening our chat can take with chick
here now maybe here attending rook t1
our queen g3 also wasn't bad
you have to check it allows Quincy eight
so I probably shouldn't do anything like
that just keep the ruger tectum attacked
him then so that Queen age seven I can
just take it check now aged for us
hanging as well white resigns yeah well
I'm glad to have 11 a game really it's a
bit strange at the moment yeah around
here this is a typical position for this
for this opening it's a very solid set
up for white not weakening anything and
so on and here well I try to exchange
some stuff this is a surprising move of
course giving up the strong Bishop I
don't really think it is good and here
this is just just good for black i mean
i didn't i didn't really appreciate it
beforehand but the the diff the defiled
control is just important and this is
just just a really really bad structure
Queen B 5 is also a good move but this
keeps this keeps an edge no doubt yeah I
think I played it and good and good
enough way just returned yes I always
kept a captain action that's that that's
reassuring okay thanks for watching